I got rhythm in my bones I got ROM in my
bones you know I'm saying in my blood so
when I here at doe betta I just have to
go my imagery is a lot darker and less
you know it's not easy to swallow to
some people you know I mean but I won't
change it for the world
I'm actually doing music cuz I love to
do it you know I don't have to do it but
I wanted to do it because that's all I
know
because I always had something special
yeah I just been waiting on everybody to
[ __ ] get it he's a rapper songwriter
record producer actor and entrepreneur
he sold over 2 million albums and have
had his songs featured in film TV and
video games he's one of the biggest
selling independent rappers in the
United States
he's tec-9 and here is my take on his
top 10 rules for success rule number 3
is my personal favorite and make sure to
stick around
although to young for some special bonus
clips also Aztec Knight is talking if he
says something I was really meaningful
to you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people could be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I got rhythm in my bones I got ROM in my
bones you know I'm saying in my blood so
when I hear Adobe da I just have to go
you know even if I'm tired and life is
tough because of the divorce and let up
yet you know I'm saying it my little my
young one that's sick you know I'm
saying family is turning on you cuz I'm
money and like that
still when that don't beat hit you're
compelled to write on it you don't say
the bus on it you know I'm saying as
long as I stay that way may I just turn
45 November 8th I don't feel like that
I'm gonna slow down no time soon brother
well a lot of artists don't know that
they got to get on the goddamn Road and
tour you know so you gotta give the
people knowing about you man you know
not just your hot single man you got to
get out there in politic how do you
politic I'm torn man you don't stand
merchandise did you got a shirt with
your name on it you got a hat with your
name on it you know these people are
walking billboards you know exactly you
know you got you got to get out there in
politic man and that's how we did it man
we just stayed on the road it feels like
seven people in the audience when we
went we didn't say okay Wayne going back
to San Diego because the only seven
people there or we ain't going back to
New York we only had ten people there we
kept coming back and hammering over
hammering them over the head and the
seven turn to a hundred one hundred turn
to five hundred you know Stan's is
selling out every time we got to change
venues you know say you got to get out
there and politic man you got to get out
there and tour we got to get out there
and sell your merchandise man and a lot
of people you know I think I'll tell you
this but it take a little money to start
your own label you feel me to take a
little money to start it you know I mean
so all you [ __ ] telling that's been
the hood put in something good if it's
in your heart we have to push for if
it's in your heart because I'm from
Kansas City Missouri who would ever
thought that you can build an empire but
if you put your mind to it
and push for to push for to keep no
matter if your family tell you it's a
hobby you need to do something else to
get money or whatever man is
if you believe in and you got to follow
their dreaming a hard man because if I
didn't that wouldn't be in any strange
music to come to any interview in
because I followed my dream after
everybody knocked me down you have to
push forward if you believe in it you
will achieve in it just gotta keep
pushing that's what I have to say Paula
Morris asked me once you write something
and rap instead of spitting on everybody
and I wrote it and everybody liked it
and I started doing it more and then I
finally won a contest first thing I've
ever won of my life the thing I one fell
on my graduation day so I chose to open
up for EPMD and kwame in all those
people at Kemper Arena in Kansas City
Missouri rather than walk across the
stage right up the street where all my
partners were graduating and that's when
I knew what I was gonna do for the rest
of my life you know your graduation days
you get your diploma and you choose
something else and then you end up doing
what you do which you planned on doing
and you're young and it's not written in
blood that you're gonna make it and you
you move from house to house because you
run away from home at 17 you move from
place to place with family members and
friends and everything trying to do
music and then you end up doing it then
you end up on the Forbes list and
working with all the people that
inspired you like ice cube and the the
doors and Roger Troutman and you know
it's wonderful you know I'm saying so
that was the most monumental to me you
know I write my life I'm not like a lot
of rappers you know I'm sand or write
what's what they think it's hot or now
all right what's happening in my life
whether it's partying
whether it's sorrowful whether it's
confused you know what I mean I'll write
that and with that being said what
inspires me and it says either reading
something
or having something happen to me that's
why I don't believe in writer's block
I mean only thing I believe in a style
blog how am I gonna save this too so
make them listen
narcissistic it's hard to grip it to the
doctors with this most prolific Mars
with the Stars this is Boris put the
ball but the our script is hard to
perfect yes but I would have been a
better market it's good enough that any
liquor starts interested
it's like style block is is the thing
but writer's block knows ever my very
first album in 96 was the calm before
the storm so I knew 20 years later if I
named this album the storm was gonna
push me to do the best music I could
possibly do and I did it and I know I'm
supposed to say that
but it's real what makes you say that um
because I'm always feeling like I have a
chip on my shoulder enough to prove
myself because I'm the weird kid you
know I'm saying because I you know I
look different I paint my face this that
no other you know saying my imagery is a
lot darker and less you know it's not
easy to swallow to some people you know
what I mean but I won't change it for
the world because they gotta accept all
of me not just one dimension of me you
know what I mean but when you got that
other dimension going up you know what I
mean like hook go crazy and fragile you
don't saying people tend to try to say
you should just do that one thing but
I'm three you don't saying I'm not one
so they gotta accept all of me always
knew that I had some special and that's
just validation after all these years
for Eminem to come through for Slipknot
to come through and do that for me and
I've been a maggot since 99 for those
who don't know what a maggot is it's a
slipknot fan you know since a metal band
you know for those people to come
through for me that I've been working
wanting to work with for over a decade
and you have to take the beat to these
people and the thought like you have to
give them something that they really
like I had to play that for Corey Taylor
backstage at a arena you know while
you're playing it are you like watching
their facial expressions to see if
they're whether are you looking down or
well I'm at a point my
well I know the stove yes so I'm playing
it for them like smile and you're like
you know and they list it to me and you
know they hear some my legs and they
start smiling and I start smelling some
more and then they'll and then Cory
Taylor are like okay whatever you're
like woah oh yes you know says so it's
just it feels wonderful to work with
people that you've been listening to for
over a decade and being right there with
them and they with you all the way man
you know I mean it it's I have no words
a lot of words I have no words just
deceit like you so excited about it you
know some people been in the industry
and then there's like yeah albums coming
out and then oh you're a highbrow it's
like a whole new life and energy we're
all it is a whole new life every time an
album comes out man but this one is by
far my best work in my opinion I'm
actually doing music cuz I love to do it
you know I don't have to do it but I
wanted to do it because that's all I
know
fragile was good or a really good song
but its political man you know I'm
saying they don't know what to do with
you you know so now that everybody but
me is just me and we're busy on the hook
yo Chris calico it's gonna be harder
because they just got sell me yeah like
okay you ain't got no features on it not
Kevin gates do not you know I'm saying
which I love Kevin gates yeah not Kevin
gauge you don't have a future on it and
you don't have a young thug on it but
it's just take 9 ok we'll see let's
listen it's a good song yeah so it's
working but we gonna see ya you know
saying it's harder it's harder so people
your question was you know is it weird
that everybody's on the jock right now I
expected it because I always had
something special yeah I just been
waiting on everybody to [ __ ] get it
I wanted to be I wanted to tec-9 to be
my favorite emcee times so I painted him
that way you know I actually painted him
- he may be in regular form I'm really
respectful but when that face paint go
along is that why you do it to sort of
transform into another character the
face paint I think there's not transform
into another character on time up I
think it's like shielding me and what's
inside of me actually but sitting there
will come out you know something I
wouldn't regularly say to people in
regular form you know I'm saying we go
pretty side dude so that face pain is
kind of like a shield like okay I can
hide buying this and say whatever the
guy want to you know so I can tell the
world that I'll give you know same thing
about love off you up so yeah I think
that face paint does a lot for me he you
know I know it does I feel like a
superhero I want people to know
that I'll bring love the music man you
know just like I bring happiness even if
it's dark man you know a lot of the
soldiers from Afghanistan come to me and
they say you got me through when I was
over there man your music got me through
doctors come to my shows a man that song
the rain were you talking about be away
for your children and felt it you know
athletes come to me man that's all you
know I'm Sam ride maker gets me pumped
up before the show the army
james hetfield Italica say we love
einstein you know I'm saying we listen
Einstein for Joel
you know just crazy stuff I want to be
remembered for the guy that brought
happiness you know semuc guy that
brought that stuff that was so
influential man I mean even if I'm
talking about me almost dying from drugs
you know
I've been clean for like four years I
know it doesn't look like a lot of
stress on that Berkeley four years
I just want to be the guy that they know
that was 100%
inside out he gave everything reward is
great my fan base keeps growing and
growing
right before my eyes
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mad-marlin asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what a tec-9 say that had the
biggest impact on you what did you learn
from this video that you're going to
immediately apply to your business or
life please leave it in the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to jennifer price
Jennifer thank you so much for being in
the book helping with the book but also
taking that awesome picture while you're
doing Christmas shopping and posting it
as well I really really really
appreciate it so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon
but but here's the thing no people see
you on stage they see on tour for years
we know you do well yeah I'm just
documenting but I try to get on lookers
fans listeners to understand that
there's no difference and it's
necessarily in people know so we all
have the same emotions same emotions we
all go through the same issues and even
though you see tec-9 on this show sway
in the morning you might see them on
some award show stage behind closed
doors he's experienced the same thing
your neighbor might be experiencing you
know yeah right and that's how we make
fans man you know Sam we that brings us
down to on a level playing field you
know I mean because they look at us
elevated on the stage they automatically
looking up so when you tell them I'm
having a bad day because my people are
turning on me and I thought these people
were real it brings us on a level
playing field they like he feels just
like me you don't say no that's how we
make fans you know saying I tapped into
emotions yeah and a lot of my fans know
about my life because I put it in my
records you know I mean to where the
wife uses that when this rain came out
or well she didn't like that you know
saying back then but this ring is like
the best song I ever wrote
pain works you know I mean so when I
when I did the song I loved you before
you she said don't write nothing else
about me if it ain't positive when I
said okay my little girl rainbow said
this she didn't like me to do the lewd
stuff on stage I would do like seven
words the song seven words and lay in
between the ladies you know so I stopped
that you know I'm saying it's like I do
what they say you know sandy the ladies
gotta take care of you no I'm saying and
Aaliyah she's just she's 22 now man
she's out there and Oakland man just
having a wonderful time doing
broadcasting and everything she don't
have too many problems yeah yeah rainbow
I can't really talk about what's going
on with my little one because you don't
want to perceive she got sick man and I
just like God why me mm-hmm you know
what I'm saying she's probably like God
why me you know saying my mama was sick
all those years and now my youngster you
saying it's like damn but in the midst
of all of that we still have time to
give ourselves to our fans and our
people that want to hear because it's a
blessing for people to want to hear
anything yeah especially these days
being in the game as long as I've been
you know what I mean is it's it's like
it's such a blessing that they still
want to listen and that's I'm gonna
forever have these stories to tell
because I'm right in my life and that's
what I chose to do back in the day when
Quincy Jones told me write what you know
and people will forever fill you